virtual reality isn't a recent invention
but thanks to the efforts of oculus it's
more viable than ever at six hundred
dollars oculus rift is expensive and
when you add the cost of an
appropriately powered PC VR as a whole
is almost prohibitively priced for the
majority of gamers after spending a week
using rift however I can look past the
price tag and see it for what it is a
key to a new era of entertainment it
lets you engage with games in ways that
haven't been possible before instilling
a tangible sense of presence that's
immediately exciting
riffs and its accompanying accessories
feel like premium products nothing about
it feels cheap or compromised well it's
hard to completely forget you're wearing
it rip never feels like a burden when
you're mentally invested in a VR
experience that said games can still
play with your senses in undesirable
ways that rift can account for on its
own adrift for example is a game about
floating through a broken space station
your body twists and turns with
simulated weightlessness and this made
me feel so uncomfortable that I had to
stop playing it it's a product of how
good rift is that convincing your brain
that what you're seeing is real and
evidence of the fact that software is an
equally important part of the equation
rift is for more than just games however
and some of the most enchanting and
least intense VR experiences are passive
there are 360 degree videos taken from
locales around the world as well as 3d
rendered short films that transport you
to otherworldly locations offering a
taste of what a virtual tourism and
storytelling will be like once VR gains
traction outside of video games in order
to get a smooth and enjoyable experience
with rift you need a better-than-average
gaming PC the requirements aren't
outrageous and some people may only need
to upgrade one or two components in
their existing PC to get started but to
build or purchase a rift ready system
will cost at a minimum close to $1,000
raising the entry fee considerably for
some customers oculus has cultivated a
wide array of games and passive
experiences for launch
and everyone who has pre-ordered a rift
gets two games for free one is Lucky's
tale a 3d platformer set in an adorable
cartoon landscape that borrows heavily
from games like super mario 64
the other is eval cream a dogfighting
game set in space with racing sports
adventure horror strategy and puzzle
games to name a few of the genres
represented in the launch lineup there
are plenty of ways to explore the
potential VR introduces to video games
of course just because the game is in VR
doesn't mean it's good by default a
Valkyrie for example is littered with
microtransactions that detract from its
initial appeal Lucky's tale while
charming and fun pads out its levels by
forcing you to replay them with
alternate objectives after five hours
battling my way through an enigmatic
dungeon Chronos is so far an amazing
game that recalls favorites like
Resident Evil The Legend of Zelda and
Dark Souls however it stumbles on
occasion due to a handful of design
flaws including the unforgiving way that
it allows you to walk into pitfalls some
of which are difficult to see due to
crow
use of fixed camera perspectives clearly
vr games are susceptible with the same
problems as regular views but there's
something about the unique VR experience
that makes up the difference at least a
little bit when I'm flying around and
Eve Valkyrie immersed in my virtual
cockpit soaring through space debris I'm
entranced by how convincing it feels
when you're playing a game on a monitor
the real world is an equal view when
that is stripped away and filled in with
the world of the game you're playing in
VR it's a very powerful experience that
traditional gaming platforms simply
don't offer $600 is a lot to pay for a
piece of gaming hardware but rift is
different from a console or a new
graphics card rift allows you to
experience games in ways you've only
dreamed of up until now and while it
does require you accept a few
compromises in the name of immersion
it's worth it
yes you will look silly to anyone who
watches you use it and you will
potentially feel uneasy after an intense
demo but these issues can't take away
from the fact that riff delivers on its
promise to enable more immersive and
personal gaming experiences than we've
ever seen before
you